f is a linear function whose table of
values is shown below so they give us
different values of x and what the
function is for each of those x's
which graphs show functions which are
increasing at the same rate as f
so how what is the rate at which f is
increasing when x increases by four
we have our function increasing by seven
so we could just look for which of these
lines are increasing at a rate of of
seven fourths seven in the vertical
direction every time we move four in the
horizontal direction an easy way to
eyeball that would actually be just to
plot
two points for f and then see what that
rate looks like visually
so if we see here when x is zero f is
negative one when x is zero when x is
zero
f is negative one so when x is zero f is
negative one
and when x is 4 f is 6 when x is 4
f is 6. so 1 2 3 4 5 6.
so just like that and two points specify
a line we know that it is a linear
linear function you could even verify
here when we increase by 4 again we
increase our function by 7 again we know
that these two points are on f and so we
get a sense of the rate of change of f
and when you draw it like that
it immediately becomes pretty clear
which of these has the same rate of
change of f
a is increasing faster than f c is
decreased increase it is c is increasing
slower a is increasing much faster than
f c is increasing slower than f b is
decreasing so it's not even even close
but d seems to have the exact same
inclination the exact same slope the
exact same slope as f so d is what we
would go with and we could even verify
it even if we didn't even if we didn't
draw it in this way our change our
change in f
for given change in x
is equal to when x changed plus four
our function changed plus seven it is
equal to seven fourths and we can verify
that on d if we increase in the x
direction by four so we go from four
to eight then in the vertical direction
we should increase by seven so one two
three four five six seven and it indeed
does increase at the exact same rate